ticket
a high-speed chase caught on dash camera
video in Maryland shows the moments a
carjacker spins out of control and
crashes in the roadway
[Music]
s
the crash happened on June 29th in
Baltimore at about two o'clock that
afternoon officers with the Charles
County Sheriff's Office responded to
reports of a woman being assaulted and a
possible carjacking that's when
officials began to chase to hunt down
the suspected driver later identified as
34-year-old DeJuan Mitchell
you know
[Music]
as the chase continued officials
confirmed Mitchell did not know the
owner of the vehicle he allegedly stole
[Music]
if you want
me
[Music]
dash camera video shows more officers
join the chase
[Music]
yet
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
this video shows the Chase from another
officer's perspective
[Music]
are there anyone
foreign
[Music]
okay okay
foreign
[Music]
University
why not
[Music]
everybody
foreign
[Music]
eventually one of the officers catches
up with Mitchell who almost hits a squad
car head on
um
[Music]
good
bye
[Music]
16.
separate dash camera video shows these
same moments from a third angle five
[Music]
aims
foreign
[Music]
as the chase picks up dash camera video
captures Mitchell brush up against the
road's median after that he loses
control spins out and crashes into a
dump truck the entire crash is caught on
camera
next multiple officers arrive on the
scene
[Music]
Mitchell was pronounced dead on the
scene the dump truck driver only
sustained minor injuries in the crash
and right now the incident is still
under investigation by the Maryland
state police crash team reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie